d'importantes controverses
au cours de son mandat.
Même si on le savait g
de vives réactions partout
sur la planète.Jean-Philippe Hus
- Nous remercions le Seigneur
aussi pour ce don qu'on a reçu
Benoît XVI.
- Un hommage à la fois sobre
et solennel, à l'image
des funérailles qu'aimerait
recevocococococococococococococ.
- Ça fait beaucoup de peine.
Il a fait beaucoup pour
le monde.- - - - - - - - - - - x
en même temps! On sait où
il est bien, où il est bien,
où il est dans le moment.
mgêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêêl
- Je ne m'attendais pas à ce que
oioioioit aujourd'hui, là.
Alors, donc, un peu surpris.
- Monseigneur Lépine gardececect
attentionnées avec le papequi le
d'archevêque de Montréal.
je dirais toujours cordiale
parce que toujours simpl
Je pense que son humilité
était proverbiale. Donc,
toujours simple, t
bienve
d'inspiration pour des millions
de personnes,
selon Justin Trudeau.
Le pape Benoît XVI,
né Joseph Ratzinger en 1927
grandi dans une famille pieuse
d'Allemagne. Ordonné prêtre
les échelons ecclésiastiques.
Jean-Paul II en fera son bras
de la congrégation de
la doctrine de la foi.
(chant religieux)
JOSEPH RATZINGER, préfet
Congrégation doctrine de la fo
- Les problèmes de la moralité
de l'homme doivent être
de nouveau pensés dans
de la foi et des grandes donnés
de la tradition huma
cocococococococococococococococe
de la société dans un monde
c c c c c changement.
En 2016, Joseph Ratzinger
est sacré pape Benoît XVI.
Un pontificat pour le moins
m m m m m marqué par
les scandales de
pédocriminalité au sein
ALAIN CREVIER, ancien animateur
de "Second regard"
- Ce qu'on lui a toujours
reproché, encore aujourd'hui
et probablement encore
ne jamais avoir dit : nous,
l'Église catholique,
on le savait, mais on a préféré
regarder ailleurs.
que mes forces avaient diminué
et j'ai demandé à
de m'éclairer.
- En 2013, sa démission
inattendue crée une onde
de choc.
- Je trouvpepepepepepepepepepep,
il avait... il avait laissé
tomber les gens qui sont
croyants
- Je pense que ce que
retiendra, c'est le fait
qu'il ait démissionné.
Il n'était pas équ
pour faire face aux magouilles,
à la corrup e e e e e e e espèce
de foire incroyable qu'étaitsons
les dernières années,
en tout cas.sesesesesesesesesess
un monastère au Vatican
dans l'ombre de son successeur
François Ier.
Radio